[MUSIC PLAYING]
VINEET BHAN: Good
morning, folks.
Thanks for taking the time to
join us today for the session.
We have a very
interesting session today.
We have a great panel of experts
from Cardinal Health, FTD, Palo
Alto joining us today, sharing
their key insights that
will help you guys
think about security
for Public Cloud
and applications
that you're building today.
So the agenda for
the session will be,
I'll start with a few slides--
five or so slides, just
explaining the key concepts,
which will be especially
helpful for folks
who are new to Public Cloud.
And then we'll
transition quickly
into the panel
discussion, and I'll
invite the panelists to
come join me on stage,
and we'll have a Q&A round.
After the panel is over,
folks in the audience
can come up and ask
questions, if there
are any questions you want
to ask any of the panelists.
So without further delay,
I think the key concept
that folks need to keep
in mind, as they're
moving into the Public Cloud,
is security will be top of mind.
And your security
in the Public Cloud
can be same as what
you have on-prem.
It could be better than
what you have on-prem.
But the way security
will be implemented
in Public Clouds would
be different than what
you have done on-prem.
As an example, in Google
Cloud, there a lot of services
you could use.
You could be using GCE, GKE,
or you could be using Storage.
And for example, for GCES
and other storage services,
the access to those services
is controlled through APIs.
So when you're thinking about
securing those services,
you have to think about what
services, what controls,
what policies you
would have in mind,
so people don't have access
to the storage that is being
managed by Google for you.
There are a couple
of key concepts
that you have to
think about when
you're thinking about security
for your applications.
One is, how do you protect
from the edge of the network
to close to your workload?
That's the core of your network,
or to the endpoint itself.
So there will be
layers of security,
and I'll double-click to
explain what the layers are.
And the other key
concept to think about
is there will be different
levels of security rules
you would apply.
So it will start from course
rules that apply to everything,
and then they'll move on
to more fine-grained rules
that you can apply to control
at the microservice level.
So as you're thinking about
how to take care of security,
you ought to broadly think
about some of these concepts.
So just double-clicking
to give you guys
a quick flavor of
what this would mean.
So for example, if you're
protecting your web
application, you
have to think about,
how do I do DDoS
mitigation, or how do I
protect my applications
from layer 7 attacks?
And you would do
that by, for example,
using the global load
balancer we have,
and the Cloud Armor
product that was
part of the keynote today,
and the IAP product, as well.
So you would use that product.
You could have rules--
layer 3, layer 4 rules,
or layer 7 rules--
that will protect the
public-facing, internet-facing
applications you have.
So that will be the protection
at the edge that I spoke about.
And then, you will bring it
closer to your VPC parameter
and think about, at your VPC
perimeter level, what kind
of securities do you build?
And how do I lock in
access to my data?
How do I lock in my access
to the applications?
And you will do that
with VPC-level firewalls.
This is where you
could have rules
like, I only want HTTPS traffic
coming in from the internet,
so it will implement those
rules at your VPC level.
And the example that
I shared about GCS,
and having controls
on who to access this,
you will do that using
the VPC Service Controls.
So those are the
key concepts you
have to think about when you're
protecting your perimeter.
Use the VPC Service Controls,
use the native firewall
that we have.
Then, taking it to
the next level down,
now most customers would
want to have more detail,
more fine-grained controls.
Controls like add to your
service account level,
what your service accounts
can do, cannot do.
What services they can touch,
what data they can access.
So you would have the next
level of security there at GKE
level, at different
IAM policy level,
to bring your controls
to that level.
And all of this is
greatly complemented
by partner products, so there
are native Google products that
will provide you different
levels of security,
but you should complement them
with partner products that
are--
we have a broad ecosystem
of partner products,
and you should think about
how partner products would
help you complete your
security story for GCP.
So I'll just show you
a quick picture on--
I will not cover all
these boxes here,
but this is just a
quick review for you
to explain how partner products
complement what Google does.
So there is a foundation
infrastructure level
that is covered by Google.
But if you go above that
level into Storage Network,
you will add on partner
products to provide
complementary security services.
You know, things
like brand products
like next-generation
firewalls is something--
you would work with companies
like Palo Alto Networks,
and use their production
and their products
to complement the products
and services that Google
has to protect you.
So your overall
security architecture
would be a combination of
what we natively provide
and partner products
that we have.
So I think those were the key
concepts I wanted to cover,
I think especially for
folks who are new to GCP.
So they understand how
we think about security,
how partners come into
the picture, and so on.
One key concept that
I wanted to add on
before we call in the panelists
was the shared VPC concept.
It's a very powerful concept.
If you haven't
looked at it so far,
I would recommend
you take a look.
And just taking a step back
of why this is powerful,
the key problem that
people had in public clouds
was in every department, every
app owner taking your credit
card, creating
their own projects,
and there would be
thousands of projects.
And the central
security team, IT team,
would have no control
on those projects.
In Google, that
problem was solved
using the organization concept,
and having a shared VPC
architecture, where
you would have a host
VPC that your security
team, your IT teams,
can implement their
policies, define the subnets,
have a next-gen firewall like
Palo Alto in your host VPC,
and have a centralized
way of managing policies
for all the service
projects that your app
owners are creating.
So your app owners can
have the flexibility
of creating the
projects they want,
without having to
worry about security.
And you, as the security
admin, have the control,
using this shared VPC concept,
by having your security defined
at the host project level.
And the routing of all the
traffic to the host project,
having centralized policies
are done in one place.
And when I explain this concept
to our partners, key customers,
they are saying, hey,
this is the closest
we have seen we can get to
the old on-prem, centralized
control model.
So this is a very
powerful concept.
It helps you do
security at scale,
and from a centralized fashion.
So if you haven't taken
a look at the shared VPC,
please take a look.
It also gels very well
with our partner products,
like the Palo Alto
VM series firewall
and they plug in beautifully
into the shared VPC model.
With that, I would like to
invite the panelists to join me
on the stage.
So Rob, from Cardinal
Health, Bill, FTD, and Sanjay
from Palo Alto Networks.
I think, just to
start off, I think
it will be great to
start with introductions,
so folks know what your
roles are in your companies.
And then we'll go deeper into
your journey into Google Cloud,
and how you thought
about security.
So Rob, if you could go
first with introductions?
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT: Yeah, sure.
Hi.
I'm Rob Ravenscroft.
SPEAKER 1: Sorry.
One second.
If you'd like to ask a
question, please step
to the mics in the aisles.
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT: OK.
VINEET BHAN: And we'll
keep the questions
for the end of session.
So we'll do the panel
questions, and then open up
the floor for questions.
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT: OK.
Yeah, I'm Rob Ravenscroft.
I'm with the
security architecture
team at Cardinal Health.
We have a great partnership
with our Cloud services,
Cloud engineering team, which
I think is very important.
The reason that we looked
at going to Google and GKE
is simply speed, scalability,
and obviously, security.
That's very important to me.
VINEET BHAN: So
Bill, if you could
do your introduction, as well.
BILL O'BRIEN: Yeah.
I'm Bill O'Brien from FTD.
So it's a florist
and gifting company.
I manage the network
in the telecom group.
But we work very closely with
security and the Cloud team.
So we're a pretty
small organization
going into the Cloud.
So we have a lot of
different hats that we wear.
So the more knowledge
that we have
for the different areas,
the better off we're
able to execute.
VINEET BHAN: Sanjay,
please introduce.
SANJAY GUPTA: Thanks.
Hi.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Sanjay Gupta.
I am Director of
Product Management
at Palo Alto Networks for
virtualization and cloud
security.
And as part of the
role, my team is
responsible for
building products right,
specifically VMCs,
next-generation firewall
for securing public cloud
infrastructure and networks.
So as part of the
role, I participate
in a lot of customer
discussions,
and particularly,
Cloud-related advisory boards
and product councils.
So really happy to be here to
share some of my perspective
to you guys to help
you in your journey.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you, Sanjay.
So I'll start with
Rob-- just trying
to understand your
journey into GCP.
What made your company
decide to be on GCP?
And when you were thinking
about security, how
did you think about security?
And how did you think about Palo
Alto being part of that answer?
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT: Yeah.
That was an easy one.
Google has always been
known for security,
ever since Gmail came out.
And just the advances
since then, it
made it pretty easy to
look at Google and GCP.
Palo Alto-- I have
about 20 years
of network security experience.
So I've worked with every
different type of firewall
that you can think of
over the past 20 years.
Palo Alto pretty
much changed the game
when they came out with
the next-gen firewall.
So I was very excited
to see that they
have a partnership with Google.
VINEET BHAN: Thank you.
So I think, Bill,
similar question to you.
So about your GCP
journey, and how
do you think about
security there?
BILL O'BRIEN: Yeah.
So from our organization,
we had, basically,
a very monolithic
web brand that we
had when he had six
different brands out there.
And each one was basically
taking up its own space.
So they brought in some new
leaders into the organization.
And they basically said,
hey, we need to bring
this stuff together, right?
So we had an initiative
to basically take
all of those brands and
bring them into the Cloud.
So we basically had a
bake-off between Google
and another vendor.
And Google won out
primarily because of the GKE
and being able to--
how Google has that set up
to be able to be managed.
Because one of the things is
that, being a small company,
you don't want to be experts
in everything, right?
So the things that
you can actually
farm off to another
company, the better off
you're actually going to be.
So this way, you can actually
focus on the business
and actually focus
on technology.
So that was one of
the big drivers.
And in Palo Alto, we already
had Palo Alto in-house.
And as soon as we found out--
because we basically went
to the Google Cloud in January.
And then we had to
have it stood up
by Mother's Day, which was
basically by the end of April.
So within four
months, we basically
decided to go with Google Cloud.
And then we actually
started to roll it out.
And as soon as we did that, they
started talking with Palo Alto
and see if they had
actually a beta program.
And then we actually got it
[? running ?] from there.
VINEET BHAN: And how
was the Mother's Day
experience for you?
Were things smooth?
BILL O'BRIEN: It was, actually.
Yeah.
So we actually had
Akamai in front of it.
So we were actually able to
load how much we were going
to send to the legacy site,
and how much we were actually
going to send to GCP.
So at what point--
if you actually put
the domain in directly,
we actually had 100% of
that traffic going into GCP.
VINEET BHAN: Great to hear that.
Thank you.
And so Bill, one more
question for you,
just double-clicking on
what you have on GCP.
What kind of
workloads do you run?
And how much are you guys
into containers, GKE?
Any insights that you can
share with the audience?
BILL O'BRIEN: Yeah.
We're extensively GKE.
So when we actually
first spun it up,
we wanted to use shared VPCs.
But at that time, shared VPCs
weren't available onto the GKE
clusters.
So what we ended
up having to do was
we ended up having to create
VPNs within GCP itself
to go from the shared VPC into
the GCP into the GKE cluster.
But now, they've actually
brought that inline.
And one of the biggest
things that we actually
saw with Google was
how quickly they're
able to move things
from alpha to beta
to actually having
it provisioned out.
And even-- each day you go
onto the Google console,
and all of a sudden,
you see a new pop-up.
And it's just like,
hey, what is this?
What is this going to be doing?
And all of a sudden,
then that's where
IAM comes really into play.
Because the more people have
the ability to make changes,
the more dangerous
it's going to be.
So all of a sudden, as new
features get turned up,
you want to be able to
make sure that you actually
control the access.
Because all of a sudden,
they're going to be like, hey,
what does this button do?
And all of a sudden,
they'll click on that.
And then you won't
know what happened.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you.
So, Bill, question for you.
Similarly, if you could
double-click on what kind
of deployment you have and what
you're using for GKE or any
other--
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT: Rob, sorry.
Yeah.
Right now, we have a lot
of non-production workloads
out there.
My two experts in this
space, actually three,
are in the front two rows here.
So if we get to the Q&A,
I might bring them up
to answer more
detailed questions.
But really, I would start
with non-production,
obviously, get familiar with it.
And if you have the DevOps
mentality or methodology,
make sure that you have
very good ops, not just dev.
So understand routing,
networking, at the start of it.
That will definitely
help you out.
VINEET BHAN: Thank you.
Sanjay, a question for you.
You must be talking
to a lot of customers
and hearing from them about
how they're moving into Cloud.
Any insights, customer
stories you have on where
you see customers heading?
And what are the key trends
there, or key challenges,
that you're seeing?
SANJAY GUPTA: Sure.
Thanks, Neet.
So clearly, I think everyone
knows that Cloud is definitely
getting more mainstream, if not
in terms of real deployments,
but I definitely see
in terms of interest.
Containers are, I'd say,
relatively new, or newer.
So not many customers are, I'd
say, onto it at this point.
But two main
perspectives I would
like to share, which strike
me when I speak to customers.
The first one is
about the difference
in perspective,
or point of view,
between the business
and the CSOs.
So businesses typically think
that the IT and the security
is not moving fast enough.
While, if you talk to a lot of
CSOs and the security folks,
they think that the business
is pulling them in very hard.
So there's this big disconnect
between the speed at which
the business wants to move and
the speed at which the security
folks want to move, right?
And I'd say that the relatively
few successful organizations
I've seen is where the
security folks actually
have taken the baton.
And they are essentially moving
at the same speed, or even
faster, than the business.
And those organizations,
I can see,
are really being very proactive,
and moving and innovating
at a faster speed.
The second perspective
which I see
is the fact that it's like--
is the chasm.
It's a chasm between the folks
who have jumped onto the Cloud,
and they have started
their cloud journey,
versus the folks who have not.
And one of my realizations
has been that, hey, Cloud
is obviously all about speed.
But it's also about
innovation and being
able to adapt and iterate.
Because I'd say that most
Cloud providers, including
Google itself, as
Bill just mentioned,
they're coming out with new
services at a phenomenal rate.
So you should be willing
to both apply security
at the right speed, as
well as willing to iterate
with these Cloud providers and
improve your security controls
and security
mechanisms over time.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you, Sanjay.
So, Sanjay, one more
question for you.
So as customers and
folks in the audience
are thinking about
security, what
are your thoughts
about what key things
they need to keep
in mind when they're
thinking about security-- when
they're thinking about moving
more and more workloads
into the Cloud?
What are the key things that
you would recommend them to keep
at the top of their list?
SANJAY GUPTA: Sure.
So I'll start off and extend
what I was saying before.
So the first thing is--
so I'd say there are
two things overall.
One is speed.
And second is new and
different attack surfaces.
So as you're moving into
Cloud, and your applications
and workloads into
Cloud, you have
to realize that Cloud
is all about speed.
So that means that
the security also
has to be able to move at
the speed of the Cloud.
Which means that the security
has to get highly automated,
like your applications
and workloads are.
Number two, the security has
to become more Cloud native,
which basically means it has to
get integrated into your Cloud
environments and leveraging
the Cloud services,
which the Cloud
infrastructure is offering.
And that is going to give
it that Cloud native flavor.
And the last, and this one is
that security fundamentally
has to shift left,
which basically
means security has to get
more ingrained with the AppDev
lifecycle.
It shouldn't remain disjointed
from the application,
development, and
deployment itself.
And that is why, at
Palo Alto Networks,
we lay a lot of
emphasis on that.
And there are a lot of
product capabilities,
including automation, tight
integration with Google Cloud,
as well as making our
policies more and more
automated is what we invest
on on the product side.
And then, the second aspect
is that, as you are thinking
about the Cloud
security, you have
to realize that there are
some things which have changed
in the cloud, right?
Which means that there are
some attack surfaces which have
gotten minimized or gone away.
As Vineet was showing the slide
earlier, the infrastructure,
which is the ownership of the
Cloud providers-- of Google,
in this case--
is going to be secured
by Google themselves.
But then, there are new attack
surfaces which have opened up,
which basically means
things like past services
that you're going to consume
in Google Cloud, right?
And you need to think about
how to secure those services.
And that may mean
that you will have
to look at new mechanisms
and ways, particularly more
API-centric mechanisms and ways,
to secure your environment.
So those are the two
main points, in summary.
One is the speed
and how you make
sure that your security
operates at the speed
of the application.
And number two, be very aware
of the way the attack surfaces
have changed in
this environment.
And then how you can secure
those new attack surfaces.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect, Sanjay.
Those were great insights.
So, Bill, a question for you.
You decided to go
down to GKE path.
What were the key security
aspects or concerns
you had to think about when
you decided to go production?
And you guys had a
limited time frame
to get the security
right, as you
were ramping up production
and for Mother's Day.
So can you share some
key insights there?
BILL O'BRIEN: Yeah.
So with GKE, they
primarily went with GKE
because of the security that was
already handled within Google.
So because they've already had
that pretty much established,
it was good for them
to be able to use that
and for us to be able to go
and move forward with that.
So because we had such
a short time window,
we basically-- what we did was
we stood up a QA environment
for them.
So we spun up a QA environment
that had a VPN connection back
onto on-prem, so
they could actually
start pushing out their code,
building their clusters,
and start doing a
lot of development
and so forth, till we actually
figured out what the production
environment was actually
going to look like
and how big it
actually needed to be.
And from the slide that
was up there before,
with the VM series that we ended
up spinning up to Palo Alto
and having multiple
interfaces off of it.
So we had production, we
had pre-prod, we had PCI.
And then we basically
had a services one.
And then there was
a DMZ side, as well.
And on the DMZ side,
that was basically
where we had the shared VPC
to allow you to connect back
onto on-prem.
So within the GKE,
it had to do a lot
with the controls
and the clusters
and everything like that.
So it just provided a lot of
out-of-the-box features that
just allowed the management for
us to be spun up very quickly.
And then it took a lot of
things off of our plates.
So that way, then, we don't
have to worry about OS patches
and things like that.
And then also, it handles
the internal load balancing
and things like that, as well.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you.
So, Rob, similar
question for you.
As you guys were
implementing, how
did you think
about what products
you would use within
Google or partner products?
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT: Yeah.
I think, first, the key
is having that partnership
with the CSO organization.
Our vice president spoke
yesterday, John Latchaw,
and talked about,
take your CSO out
for a few beers, or his
favorite beverage, repeatedly.
Keep them on your side.
That partnership is
critical from the start.
You don't want to come in
and have to bolt on security,
or be given a stack
of requirements later.
So really, partner
with the security team.
So our journey was
really good because we
have this great
partnership at Cardinal
Health between the teams.
And we found that regularly
meeting during weekly stand
ups, just working together,
really made a huge difference.
So as we started looking
at Cloud Native first--
that's always what
were challenged to do--
what can you secure, by default,
within the cloud provider?
And then, if you get through
all those requirements,
you do identify a few gaps,
where something like Palo Alto
is required, primarily
ingress and egress protection
from the internet.
So in a highly regulated
environment, HIPPA, GDPR now,
you have to have those
protections in place.
But I would urge
everybody in the room,
look at the Cloud Native first.
Stretch that to its
limits, and then
start to look at
the third parties.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
So thanks for that.
So going back to
Sanjay-- to you.
From Palo Alto Network's
perspective, what are your--
I think you shared
a lot of insights.
Are there any
recommendations, in terms of,
as the customer is going
through this cloud journey,
on how they should interface
with you and Google?
Any other recommendations
they should
keep in mind on how to go
about thinking about security?
SANJAY GUPTA: Sure.
Thanks, Neet.
So fundamentally, I think
that, in many respects,
going to Cloud from a
security perspective
is no different than
previously, which
is that the core
principles of security
still apply, and are as
relevant to Cloud as they
were for any environment.
And those core principles being,
which we all really believed
in, is the fact that A, you need
to have complete visibility,
in terms of what is going
on in that environment.
B, you need to be able to,
from that point onwards,
be able to minimize
your attack surface,
which is basically the security
principle of least privilege.
So that means that only
the necessary activity,
whether it's the
traffic, it's user
activity, it's transactions, is
happening in that environment.
And then, once you
have that as the base,
then you manage any known
threats in that environment.
So you can block them and
control them and prevent them
right away.
And then, on top of
that, we have the ability
to be able to detect and
remediate any unknown threats.
So those are the core
security principles
that we have been operating
on for the last 12 years,
since Palo Alto Networks
have been founded.
And I believe that they're
equally applicable to Cloud.
The thing which is
different about the Cloud
is, how do you
apply those security
principles and those security
controls in this environment?
Which is, essentially,
about making sure
that these things can be applied
at the speed of the cloud.
And these things can be applied
across all attack surfaces,
even some of those
new attack surfaces
I was talking about previously.
So specifically,
our recommendation
for cloud security
is that, hey, to be
able to achieve that,
you need to look
at multiple dimensions
of your cloud deployment,
which is network, end
point, and the APIs.
So on the network--
as Rob was mentioning,
on the network,
you should be able to
get visibility and be
able to control your
inbound and outbound traffic
into your cloud deployment,
as well as be able
to segment, across multiple
applications or workloads that
may be deployed in the cloud
environment, what Vineet was
talking about-- the shared VPC.
That's a great step
forward from Google,
which allows you
to be able to do
that in a much more effective
and efficient fashion.
So with that you can
have a good control
on who can access
your applications
and what kind of
access is happening
for those applications.
Beyond that, on
the endpoint, you
need to make sure that there is
no malicious activity happening
and there is no [INAUDIBLE]
exploits happening.
So you need to have
mechanisms so as
to be able to control the
security and the endpoint.
And then, lastly,
it's about the fact
that, as you go more
and more Cloud Native,
you will actually
consume more and more
of Cloud Native services,
which is the great services
that the Cloud providers--
that Google-- is building
into their environments.
You would use their storage.
You would use their database
as a service, right?
You will use managed
GKE as a service.
And as you do that,
you may, in some sense,
lose complete visibility, in
terms of what is going on.
And you need a mechanism
through which you can basically
understand what is going
on in this environment,
and be able to apply
your corporate policies
on the data which is
being stored and operated
upon in these environments.
And the best way to
do that is a platform,
like Google provides
very rich APIs,
and that is what
we have looked at.
And via APIs, through
tools like Evident,
we can actually give you
that complete visibility
and monitoring of
what is happening
in these environments,
as well as
let you apply the
enterprise policies,
in terms of what is allowed
and what is not allowed.
And if anything happens
outside of the norm,
you can auto-remediate.
So for example, you
could say, you know what?
I do not want any workload which
is getting new workload, which
is getting deployed
in my Google VPC,
to have internet access
unless it has been
approved by the policy, per se.
And if anything
like this happens,
then automatically stop and
prevent that from happening,
or automatically deploy a
next-generation firewall
in front of the
workload, so that you
have complete control over the
ingress and egress traffic.
So that is what is important.
So in summary, I believe
that, in a cloud deployment,
the same security
principles apply.
And you need to look at it from
all the dimensions of network,
endpoint, and APIs.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you.
And I completely agree
with what Sanjay said.
We've been working
closely with our partners
to make sure the partner
products are integrated.
And we think about security
in the Cloud more in terms of,
how can we make security
better in the cloud than what
was on-prem?
How do we make it
more automated?
Everybody knows
there is a shortage
of security professionals.
So how do we get ahead of that
problem by automating it more?
So it's still early days,
but we're working closely
with our partners so
we can make security
as seamless as possible,
as automated as possible.
And we're looking forward
to more and more innovation
together.
SANJAY GUPTA: Sure.
And maybe, just to
add to that, yes, we
are definitely working
very closely with Google
in that direction, in terms of
building native integrations
into Google services
like Stackdriver,
[? autoscaling ?] function,
building integrations with GKE.
So you can define
your security policies
using Kubernetes label in
GKE, and be able to enforce,
without you having to type--
learn about IP addresses
or other mechanisms of how
you apply security policies.
So all of that,
essentially, I'd say,
are the foundational
building blocks
which allows you
to have security
move at the speed of the
Cloud, and be very seamlessly
deployed and operated
in these environments.
VINEET BHAN: Yes.
Thank you.
So, Bill, a couple
of questions for you.
I think you had a great
experience deploying
something in GKE.
In the container
world, GKE world,
there are new sets
of challenges,
new kind of securities
people have to think about.
And also, companies,
in some cases,
have to rethink how their teams
are organized because things
are moving at a different pace.
So any insights on what
were the new things
that you had to think about, in
terms of security challenges,
in terms of people organization,
how teams should be structured?
It would be especially
helpful for folks
who are new into the GKE world.
And what are the key
things that are very unique
because you are
on the GKE stuff,
or as people are moving into
the more containerized world?
BILL O'BRIEN: Yeah.
I think one of the
biggest challenges
was that it's going
into the cloud, right?
You just don't know
what is actually
connected to what, right?
You're just assuming
that, hey, Google
has their stuff together.
And be like, OK, hey,
how can we actually
make sure this is
actually occurring, right?
And so I was actually
in a presentation
yesterday about compliance.
And one of the things in
there was to trust, but then
to verify, right?
And one of the things of
actually going into GCP
was that it's such an unknown
thing, that it was just like,
all right.
At least if we could have one
common thing that we actually
know--
so if we were just
like, hey, we're
going to put the
Palo Alto there,
and we know that everything has
to flow through the Palo Alto,
then we can actually see
what the flows are actually
going to occur.
So this way, then, we
can actually trust that.
But then, as a GKE, they
started to spin things up.
And all of a sudden,
it was just like,
hey, we need connectivity
between here and there,
and so forth.
So then we actually
started to build that.
So a lot of people who used
to be spending time building
servers and so forth are now
becoming DevOps managers.
They're working on DevOps to
be able to push things out
through that.
So even more on the security
side, where it's just like, OK,
hey.
How can we actually
go to the next level?
So like Rob had said, about
the native side of it,
where it's just like, OK, hey,
we're going to use the GLBs.
So we already have
[INAUDIBLE] on-prem,
but it's just like, all right.
Do we really need another
set of load balancers
out there, where Google already
has load balancers set up
for us to be able to do?
So we basically just
took this step of,
where do we actually
need the tools?
And how do we
actually get to there?
So even going
through the sessions
yesterday with MTLS and so
forth, where it's just like,
hey, those are going to be
things that we're actually
going to be looking at.
And the biggest
thing within security
is that it's just going to be
layer upon layer upon layer.
And I heard, yesterday,
one of the things
was a really good analogy.
It was a gentleman from Red Hat
who basically had said-- oh,
I'm sorry, he was from Netflix--
who basically said, you
don't want to build gates,
but you want to
build guardrails.
So you want to be able to know
where the traffic is actually
going.
But you don't want to just
put up so many restrictions
that it's just
like, hey, it's very
cumbersome for
the business to be
able to be flexible, and be
able to get to where it actually
needs to go.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
That goes into--
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT:
Can I add something?
SANJAY GUPTA: Yeah, absolutely.
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT:
Yeah, something
that caught my attention
there was trust, but verify.
In security, you
hear that a lot.
But I think we're moving more
to the zero trust concept.
BeyondCorp was talking about it.
Palo Alto has been talking
about it for quite some time.
Do not trust anything.
So every packet,
every authentication,
come at that with a
zero trust mindset.
But you have to do
it in a seamless way,
like you mentioned, Bill.
So don't put gates up where
gates don't need to be.
But think about not trusting
everything, instead of
trusting and verifying.
I even get in the habit
of removing that label
called Trust and Untrust.
Because it gets
you in the mindset
that everything coming
in that interface is
trusted, when it's not.
So I just wanted to
make that comment.
And then also, if you have
to change your architecture
to fit a Palo Alto in or
a Nginx, or another box,
it's probably a bad design.
So you should have a modular
approach, where your GLB--
your load balancer--
works as it's supposed to work.
And then you could insert your
security tools in between that.
You shouldn't have
to change that.
VINEET BHAN: And
Rob, similar to what
we discussed with Bill, any
kind of organizational changes,
or any structural
changes that you're
seeing because
the Cloud world is
different from
the On-Prem world?
Or even further in the
container deployments,
are they different from what
VM deployments used to be?
BILL O'BRIEN: Yeah.
So Cardinal Health actually
has a dedicated Cloud services
team.
And so it's almost
like everybody's title
has Cloud in it now.
So I think it is important
to build that team
and say, hey, we're
going to do this.
We're not just going to act
a bunch of server guys trying
to manage Cloud infrastructure.
You really have to get
training, education,
and really go all in.
But I think, as you
build that team,
make sure that
security and finance is
all a part of that ecosystem.
From the DevOps--
I'm big into calling
it DevSecOps, which
a lot of people don't like.
But I think, eventually, it'll
just be called DevOps again,
once security has
shifted left, we
have a secure CI/CD pipeline.
And then, I think it will
be called DevOps again,
at least from a security
perspective, because security
is inherent.
VINEET BHAN: Absolutely.
I think that's the vision.
Security being, as Sanjay
was saying, part of the whole
CI/CD pipeline.
Make it as transparent
as possible,
that people don't even
realize security is there.
I think that's
the nirvana state.
So Bill, I think there was a lot
of discussion in the keynote,
as well, about Istio, and how
Istio can help with security.
Any thoughts about how Istio
would come into the picture,
and how it can help folks,
and what you guys are
thinking about Istio?
BILL O'BRIEN: Yeah.
So we went through one of the
sessions yesterday on Istio.
And it's very much in
line with Kubernetes
with how Google has
basically set it up.
It just helps you to do
the job of actually helping
the business, right?
It moves you off
of actually having
to create in-depth reports,
and it gets you into MTLS.
And it gets you into
more security focus.
So that way, then, it's just
inherently built into it,
right?
So as they deploy
the applications,
as they start to pull
out the development,
it's actually already
integrated into it.
So that way, then, you can set
your policies and controls.
And it's basically,
you're ready, set.
So we're looking
forward to it, actually.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
So, Sanjay, from a security
company perspective,
where do you see
Istio playing a role?
And what is Palo Alto
thinking about Istio,
and how to gel the capabilities
that Istio brings in,
along with the capabilities that
Palo Alto products bring in?
SANJAY GUPTA: Sure.
So I'd say, I see Istio as
no different than the fact
that, hey, the Google
Cloud platform by itself
provides many of the
native controls built
in from a security point.
Istio is trying to
raise the bar and do
the similar things in the GKE
or Kubernetes environment.
So we absolutely are looking
to both integrate and co-work
with Istio, which is
Istio is able to provide
certain value, in terms
of base level security,
in terms of giving you
visibility on what is happening
in your GKE environment
or, in general,
any Kubernetes environment.
And we're actively working with
the GKE team and the Istio team
to figure out how
we can insert NG
firewall in these
environments, and what
kind of a value,
over and above Istio
provides, that we can add.
And the biggest
area that we believe
is going to be around threat,
and around threat mitigation
and threat prevention.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
I think, in the last
round of questions,
I think I'll start
with you, Rob.
Any comments on Istio, and
in your concluding remarks,
any key lessons
learned or key points,
in addition to what has
been discussed today,
that you want to share
with the audience
so they can benefit
from your experience?
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT: Yeah.
Istio, I'm really excited about.
The guys here from
Cardinal probably
saw me text them at least
100 times about Istio
in the last few days.
Because I see the
security play, how
we can do the east
and west segmentation.
We talked a little bit
about north and south,
meaning in from
the internet out--
or in and outbound
from the internet.
But there's also a problem
with east and west security,
between your containers,
between workloads.
And I think where Istio can
bring that security in between,
is definitely going
to be an advantage.
Some lessons learned,
I think, go back
to don't change the
architecture based
on a security requirement.
Try to do it transparently.
This is hard for a lot of
security operations teams
that have their
favorite endpoint
technology, their favorite
tool, that doesn't
work the same way in the Cloud.
I would say, start
to learn other ways
to do things to get
the same result.
Just don't force legacy-type
tools in the Cloud.
So that was a lesson
learned early on
that we did a little bit of that
I would urge you to not look
at.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
And Rob, just a follow-up
question to that.
Did you think, in the
old on-prem world--
I had met companies
who would say,
we have 120 security
products and more.
Do you think security--
looking a year out, is
security consolidating,
or do you see it
still fragmented?
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT: Yeah.
I absolutely see
it consolidated.
We're going through
this effort right now.
We have so many tools, more
tools than I could even name,
that don't really
talk to each other.
They're probably not
utilized, even 20%.
So I see a large focus
on consolidation,
getting the visibility to
the security operations team
that they want.
Don't [INAUDIBLE]
things 100 times
so they have to correlate that.
So simplify that so it takes
minutes to troubleshoot.
But I definitely see a
consolidation of tools.
VINEET BHAN: Thank you.
So Bill, similar question.
Concluding remarks,
any key lessons
learned that you can share
with the folks in the audience,
and your thoughts of any
consolidation in security.
Where do you see security headed
in the next couple of years?
BILL O'BRIEN: Yeah.
I definitely see security
being consolidated.
I think everybody is going
to have security basically
somewhere in their title.
It used to be DevOps security,
network security, even just
physical IT security,
and everything like that.
I want to look more into the
Google Security command center,
and see how that can actually
help benefit with this.
So even though your title might
not be-- it's just like, hey,
I might be a developer.
I might be an
administrator or whatever.
Security is just such
an important part
of everybody's job.
And that comes a little bit
from the military side of me,
as well.
But I think one of the
things for the lessons
learned is the Cloud, Google,
allows you to basically reset
your environment.
So that's one of
the biggest benefits
that I have,
especially with ours,
where it was like a
monolithic, and we wanted
to go to micro segmentation.
It basically allowed
us to fix known issues
within the network.
So instead of actually
spending money and spending
cap [INAUDIBLE],, or
spending development
time of actually fixing
something on-prem,
when you go to the Cloud, it
allows you to basically reset
at that point in time, which is
actually extremely beneficial.
Because the things that
were basically broken,
you actually have
a chance to fix.
Things that you actually
want to improve on,
it gives you a chance to
improve on those items, as well.
So I think that's one of the
big benefits of actually going
to the Cloud.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thanks a lot.
So Sanjay, last question
for you, as well.
You've been in the
security industry,
talking to thousands
of customers.
Any key insights
on where security
is headed a couple of
years down the road,
and how Palo Alto is
thinking about security
as it exists in 2020?
SANJAY GUPTA: Sure.
Thanks.
So a couple of
observations here.
So one thing I'd
say that clearly--
a couple of years down
the line, even today,
it's going to be a
multi-cloud world, right?
Which means you could be
in multiple public clouds
and in your on-prem
environments, as well.
So I think it is important
for you to think,
from your security design
architectural perspective, how
you can play in a
multi-cloud world.
And I'd say Google is
doing a great job, in terms
of building technologies
like Kubernetes,
which can allow you
to be highly portable
and operate in this
multi-cloud world.
And clearly, that
is one area where
we are extremely
focused on ourselves,
so as to let you
have the flexibility
to operate in this world without
the burden of trying to manage
a fragmented set
of environments,
and managing hundreds of tools
which are purposely built
for specific environments.
But it adds tremendous
amount of complexity
and are not utilized properly.
So that is one big
area where I see
that things are going
to move, and which
is going to be relevant
from your point of view.
The second area we see, from
a security perspective itself,
is that security is going to
be more and more of a platform
player.
I think that is the point
which both Rob and Bill were
echoing before.
The sense that for the
security to be effective,
you need to be able to correlate
different independent things
together to be able to drive
the necessary outcomes.
And best of breed,
point solutions
do not play in
that world, right?
So it's going to be more
and more of a platform play.
So you should be
looking at tools
which can operate in these
heterogeneous environments,
and are able to consolidate
multiple security
functions together.
And the last point,
though not necessarily
specifically tied
to what you said--
but I know that you've
been asking Rob and Bill
about organizations, per se--
is that I think, in
most enterprises which
have been able to
successfully cross the chasm
and move fast into
cloud environments,
there has to be an arc shift.
Which means it cannot be
teams operating in silos,
in terms of, this is
the networking team,
and this is my security team,
and this is my application
team.
The teams are coming
together as a cloud team.
And in that sense,
also, there is some kind
of a consolidation, so to speak,
of teams, which is happening.
And that is very important
to happen for cloud adaption
to be successful.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Great, great insights from
everybody on the panel.
So we have the last few minutes
for any kind of questions
that anybody from
the audience have.
There are mics on both sides.
Happy to take a few questions.
And please introduce
yourself and the company
that you work for.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Pasir.
The takeaway that
I got from here
is you can't lift and shift the
applications from your on-prem
into the cloud.
You have to rebuild it from
almost Cloud Native services
in mind.
With that said,
having tools that
are living in the
data center, would it
make sense to try
to reach their--
their reach into
the public cloud?
Or should we just leave
them behind and not
even try to move those
into the public cloud?
ROBERT RAVENSCROFT: Louis,
you want to take this one--
Mr. Lift and Shift?
AUDIENCE: So at
Cardinal Health, we've
actually been very successful
in moving our applications,
as is, from on-prem
into the Cloud.
Some applications,
depending on how
they're interacting
with the internet,
we need to make a few
slight modifications to,
like setting up a global load
balancers, things like that.
But we've migrated hundreds of
applications in non-production.
We're beginning our phase of
migrating the production apps,
as well.
AUDIENCE: And in the
past, these tools
required network
packet visibility.
Is that an issue?
Is that a thing now, where
you're losing layer one access
to this?
Do you still need that,
or is that something
that you don't even
think about anymore?
AUDIENCE: We've actually been
able to, using VPC flow logs,
and firewall allow and
deny logs in Google,
we've been able to provide
our security teams everything
they've been looking for.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
VINEET BHAN: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is John Skinner
with Shape Security.
We provide GCP-hosted AI
to prevent account takeover
of login servers.
And my question is
to both Rob and Bill.
Are there any categories
of data or applications
that are deemed still
too sensitive to move
into a public cloud?
For example, in the
case of Cardinal,
HIPAA-regulated patient
health records, or perhaps
the patient login that
sits in front of it.
Or in the case of FTD, as your
whole e-commerce platform,
and the customer
login sitting in front
of it, in the public cloud.
And if not, why not?
BILL O'BRIEN: For
us, it's obviously
PHI and HIPPA, but also GDPR.
And I'd say, absolutely not.
We can make it much more
secure in the Cloud in minutes,
versus months and years
to do that same type
of micro-segmentation.
So that's my answer.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
For credit card information, and
also for customer information,
yes, we're going to be
migrating up into the Cloud.
So it's not there yet.
But our plan is to do there.
But we're going to have
additional security around it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
VINEET BHAN: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1 We have time for
one more quick question,
and then after that--
VINEET BHAN: So question
on that side, please.
SPEAKER 1: And then after that,
you can discuss in private.
VINEET BHAN: Thank you.
Sorry.
Just one last comment.
I think, after the
session, we'll be here,
so we can take questions
after the session, as well.
Please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I'm Ian, and I'm
the CSO of the Irvine Company.
And I wanted to follow up a
little bit on that question.
There's a lot of discussion
in the GDPR world,
and how Google and
Amazon and Facebook
have the ability, from a
Cloud platform perspective,
to do BI on the back
of the data, right?
And I know that that's
on the consumer side,
not on the enterprise side.
But nonetheless, you spoke a
little bit about visibility.
Are there any assurances
that we have that,
below the line of
what we can control,
that Google has no
access or BI to our data?
Especially the PII stuff--
the health care stuff.
VINEET BHAN: So absolutely.
And this was a concern that
we have heard from customers,
as well-- other customers.
So there's a lot of work
done on access transparency.
So things like, every time, if
you guys call customer support
for Google, and customer
support goes and looks
at anything in
your organization,
any action they take, any page
they visit, will be logged.
So look at that.
I think that is--
a lot of work has been done
to make sure customers feel
very comfortable
[INAUDIBLE] from nobody
from Google is looking
into your data.
Any time they look into
the data because you called
into support, anything
they did would be logged,
and you would have visibility.
And you can see, in almost
real time, what they are doing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VINEET BHAN: Absolutely.
Thank you.
OK.
Thanks a lot.
And thanks a lot
for the panelists.
I think they had
amazing insights.
And thanks a lot to Palo
Alto Networks for helping
to make this session possible.
Thank you for coming.
BILL O'BRIEN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]